(applause)
- All right
This is like a fella show, I like it.
Well, congratulations on the film.
I was telling y'all backstage
you have to be just like freaking out.
This is a really great film
that y'all are part of.
You all did a really,
really fantastic job.
Have any of y'all played basketball,
you want to tell everybody?
You're in a basketball movie,
so I'm gonna lead with that.
(laugh)
- You haven't.
- No, I've never picked up a basketball.
(laugh)
I'm a football guy.
Yeah, I've always--
- It shows.
- It definitely shows.
- So, do y'all just like lie?
When the audition comes up, you're like,
yeah, I play all the time.
- My manager lied for me.
She told production
that I scored 17 points,
10 assists, six rebounds.
And they thought it was great
until they saw me in person.
(laugh)
- Melvin, did you ever play?
- I played a basketballer
on television a few times.
I went from playing like
the best basketball player
in a country or high school,
best basketball player in the NBA,
and I got to play Marcus was
the worst player on the team.
(laugh)
- So, what about you Will?
- I grew up playing baseball
and then I slowly like
realized that I wasn't
that great at baseball
and then I wasn't gonna
do anything with it
and kind of became a
feeder band nerd instead
and did like trombone and theater.
But I, you know, for this movie,
I worked on my shot a lot.
So, I hope it paid off.
- I know, I'm like all
those three pointers.
- We don't know if it went in.
They cut, they freeze frame right before.
- Lot of CGI.
- Make me look good,
Brandon how 'bout you?
- Oh, yeah, I've been playing
basketball my whole life.
I've been playing all sports.
I was terrible as a child,
and then I like kind of
picks it up a little bit more
and I had a little
foundation to bring to this.
- They they had a really
challenging thing,
which was the audition
was not just the acting,
but they also auditioned,
playing basketball.
So the finalists as actors
were all playing basketball
against each other.
I mean, I really felt for him, you know,
and then be like, okay,
you guys can go home.
Okay, next, you know.
And I was like, man, this is brutal.
- I am sweating in my
pants right now for you.
(laughs)
I would be like, ya know what, we lied.
I'm not really great.
Did you play sports?
Did you play basketball?
- I did not play basketball.
No, I didn't, I don't
claim to play basketball.
I never told anybody I
didn't play basketball.
You got me?
- I actually told them
I suck at basketball.
- Yeah, I was not good.
(laugh)
- And that was actually
and the director was like,
he was really funny, he said,
"That's what I'm most worried about."
You don't know The game.
I was like, I don't really know the game.
And so he was like, the acting,
this stuff, all the drama.
He was like, you gotta.
So I watched a lot of
tape of coaches and stuff.
And the thing that was
most important to me was
to develop a relationship with these guys.
Develop a kind of a rapport.
And I think we did, we had a good time.
- It's great, the chemistry is great.
I don't know.
I mean, you're all great actors
if it wasn't really great in person.
But I know that it's awkward
to ask in front of them,
but I want the T.
What is the best story,
the best Ben story?
Will, do you have one?
- You want me to start?
- Yes, I do, I'm putting you on the spot.
Don't be afraid.
- Well, Okay.
- Be afraid.
(laugh)
- [Kelly] I will defend you.
I will hold Batman back.
- Okay, well, when we were shooting,
there's a scene in the movie
I don't give away a lot.
But a skirmish breaks out and we,
you know, the benches cleared.
And I remember I'm in like
the group of all these dudes
and we're fighting and whatever.
Fake fighting.
And I just feel this
dude come up behind me
and just like grab me like this
and just rip me out of the pile.
And then I look back
and it was Ben Affleck
and I was like, that's how
strong Batman is supposed to be.
(all laugh)
(applause)
It makes sense.
I feel bad for the Joker's like henchmen.
Like, he's legit.
- Do you think Batman would
have picked the smallest guy?
To pull out of there?
(laugh)
- He would have picked you, yeah.
- If I was really strong I
would have been like, Melvin!
(laughing)
- Did anybody else get
a bear hug from Batman?
- No, but wow, man.
We were three weeks in shooting
I didn't have no lines,
We were just doing all
of the basketball stuff.
So when we had the scene
where he introduces himself
as the coach, I was so happy.
I'm like, I finally get to speak finally.
Finally!
And so I remember when I
got ready to say my lines,
and this guy cuts my line off.
And so it was, I let it slide.
I gave him so slack.
You know what I'm saying?
(laughter and applause)
- I'll let Ben Affleck slide.
- Left the heater in the back, you know?
- You are so bold!
- No, he didn't let anything slide.
Tell the story.
- No, I didn't 'cause
he did it want more time
and I was like, oh no.
I'm not taking this.
Ben Affleck who?
(laugh)
So I just remember,
I was talking with Melvin in the group.
I said, I'm about to tell Ben Affleck off.
- [Kelly] Get off my Line.
- And they were like, you
know, you crazy, don't do it.
And then I ran over and I sprinted,
and I hit it right on the
chest was like, "Hey?"
I was like, "Hey, man,
you stepping on my lines?
What's up with that?"
You know what I mean?
- [Kelly] I'm proud of my line.
I been waiting a minute to say it.
- I told him, Ben Affleck,
you're Ben Affleck?
You win this movie.
You got all the lines.
I don't got that many lines.
You know what I mean?
(laugh)
I need all the chances I can get
and I had the script,
and I was telling him that oh my God.
- This story has grown.
I mean.
- I punched him in the chest.
- The truth is I stepped on his line once.
His line was what?
(laugh)
I looked past it.
I didn't even think about it.
And then he gave the,
hey man, hey man.
Yeah, what's going on?
That's my line.
You stepped on my line.
- Don't make me sound like that.
- And now he's like, yo huh?
My line!
And I did look at the other
guys and they were like,
(groans)
- He looking at me.
It was the same clip that
they show before we came out.
- Yeah, they're spitting facts.
He cut that off.
- I was like, I did respect it.
I was like, this guy is not
gonna let any take his line.
My line is what!
I'm gonna say my line!
- That's my favorite.
That's so rogue.
And I love how your
story turned into that.
And he was like, now the line was what.
- Right?
I'm acting like I got some big monologue.
- I just, ya know, sweep the leg.
(laughing)
- It's amaze.
(claps)
- All right, I ask everyone
to bring one hashtag
throwback Thursday photo
with a story behind it.
I will go first because mine is probably
the most embarrassing.
Where's it at?
Okay, so my mom, we were real broke.
Because my mom's a teacher
and they make no money.
It's horrible.
Anyway so my mom would do this thing
where we couldn't afford
to go on vacations.
She just cut our pictures
out around our head
and then place us on landscapes.
- Oh wow.
- So this was my favorite
trip to the Swiss Alps
(laugh)
This is my favorite.
Yeah.
Like she would just take my random photos.
And here's the best part,
we didn't probably pay for that either.
The you know they give you like the one
that says like photo on it
like and you just kind of, what,
would chop the bottom off.
And then you don't have
to pay for the pictures.
Note to self.
But anyway, this was my throwback.
My mom was, well, she was artistic.
You beautiful woman you.
Brandon.
We're gonna go Brandon first.
Here's Brandon's throwback.
Oh my gosh, you're so cute.
You are so cute.
Is that fake behind you or real?
(laugh)
- You talking about the
Jheri curl behind my head?
- [Kelly] No.
- That's all real.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] No, the scene.
- No, that's fake people in the back.
- [Kelly] I know, I was just kidding.
My landscape was cooler.
- [Ben] You guys both have fake pictures.
- People are really into the fake thing.
All right, Will is next?
Let's see it.
Oh come on, so cute.
Oh you need to be in a superhero movie.
- I was everyone except
Batman, unfortunately.
(laugh)
- Yeah, but that's basically last year.
- What's going on here though?
Are you flying off the tree or what?
- I don't know, I hope
onto a ladder or something.
And I don't think that
was very high up though.
So we're good.
- All right here.
Melvin!
Melvin, you cutie.
- [Ben] Lakers.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, yeah, die hard Lakers fan.
Yep.
(applause)
- All right, Charles is next.
Let's see Charles'.
(laughter)
- [Ben] Oh my God!
- Oh my gosh, you little player.
What are you wearing a suit?
Are you in like a show?
- No, so growing up as a--
- Was is that, prohibition night?
(laughter)
- Growing up as a grown up as a kid--
- Al Capone.
- Growing up as a kid,
I use to dress like that
everyday for school.
I'm not kidding.
I used to dress like that, in suits.
All day, every day.
I was with my dad.
We was going to church.
- Is that a key ring on your chain?
- I don't even.
That's a hat on the chain,
and I don't even know what.
- That's massive rapper bling.
You're like five years old.
- [Kelly] It's amazing you're in a suit.
- Who did this, man?
This is not cool.
- A three piece?
I still can't wear a three piece suit.
- You do look like a mini Bernie Mac.
It's Awesome.
- Oh my gosh, that's actually a good one.
- It's awesome.
I would love for my kids to wear.
My youngest is three,
so I could put my boy in stuff like this,
and he still has no say.
But, we're getting close
to he won't let ya.
I can't believe you let your mom do that.
All the layers.
- I was like four or five years old.
My mom would whoop me if
I didn't do what she said.
- You know what?
We're very similar, your mom and I.
All right Ben, let's see yours.
- [Ben] Yes!
- Oh my gosh.
Look at your Grease Lightning hair.
Like, I don't know what's happening.
You are so cute.
What is happening here?
- [Ben] That is (chuckles).
- [Kelly] And you're
looking at the personals?
- That is a, yeah, yes.
That's Craigslist and I'm trying to.
That was an after school special.
The one thing I did,
one little thing I did,
besides that kids show for PBS.
The camera man said,
"I'm filming a little
after school special.
You should come in and audition."
I went in and auditioned.
It was about this little
boy and his best friend.
And this is how long ago it was.
They took out a personal ad,
there was no internet, for his mom.
'Cause it was a single mom
and he trying to set her up.
And the director came in was like,
really cool and wanted to put
their artistic bent on it.
So she was like, I think
you're a punk rocker.
I was like, I don't even
know what that means,
but apparently that's what it meant.
- You do look rock and roll.
- Yeah, Sid Vicious.
(laughs)
- I think I still win
with the fake background,
but whatever.
Who's competitive?
Not me.